alors vicaire bonsoir nous nous sommes
déjà rencontrés mickey vous étiez le
premier invité de mon émission lunettes
noires pour nuits blanches au palace à
paris en 1987
souvient de vous vous étiez plus jeune
vous non
alors on va voir à quoi ça ressemblait
magnéto serge
[Musique]
fausse croyance
en guadeloupe mais l'équation
à
[Musique]
gand
alors non à la 5e place à un temps sec
ça me joue des tours
justement
non
[Musique]
business
& gêner leur
[Musique]
smartphone
le
plus fin
[Musique]
de l'année
mission le poids
c'était différent
alors on est très heureux de vous revoir
d'autant plus que cette année mickey
vous êtes vraiment là la star de la
croisette quand on pense qu'il ya
quelques années personne ne faisait
attention à vous moi je me souviens vous
avoir vu un jour à cannes tout seul dans
un bistrot sur la croisette en train de
boire 1 un expresso personnes
s'intéresser à vous
vous souvenez de ça
ça va mieux là
bas
c'est la vie life alors vous êtes ici
pour un film qui s'appelle sin city de
robert rodriguez et frank muller avec
jessica alba rosario dawson benicio del
toro brittany murphy kleib hoeven bruce
willis elijah wood et vous vous mickey
dont c'est le grand retour au cinéma et
sur la croisette donc alors sin city au
départ c'est une bd créée en 1991 par
franck muller qui raconte comme son nom
l'indiqué sin city la ville du péché la
ville du vice une ville infestée de
flics ripoux de tueur fou de femme
fatale frank miller se méfie beaucoup de
lynwood il a été scénariste à hollywood
et il voulait pas qu'on adapte sa bande
dessinée au cinéma il avait peur d'être
trahie mais quand il a rencontré robert
rodriguez qui a fait spy kids desperados
une nuit en enfer il a été d'accord et
c'est vrai que l'adaptation qui a été
fait par rodriguez était absolument
extraordinaire il a repris les cases de
la bd pour les mettre sur l'écran on
peut dire qu'il a inventé rodriguez avec
ce film le premier film bd alors on va
regarder à quoi ça ressemble ensuite on
va en parler avec mickey rourke mickey
est ce que vous pouvez regarder votre
caméra et dire magnéto serge chez moi
magnéto serge magna touchés via you look
at the camera and you just
magnéto sa manière au siège le kenya
turc la mère heureuse de gamme j'aurais
de la bêta bientôt seul hier
[Applaudissements]
audi est morte
on m'a collé un meurtre sur le dos et
les flexions dans le court
j'ai pas j'arrive
je cherche dans ces cas là sur la scène
ont chaud agace tout juste à s'échauffer
[Musique]
oh
j'ai fait une belle connerie vous
conseiller si vite fait
[Musique]
ce guignol est incontrôlable je les
suivais jusqu ici pour être sûrs qu'il
touchera pas au filet
et tellement fragile
c'est le moment de prouver à tes potes
côté pataud car quitte à y laisser sa
peau doit flinguer tout un tas le champ
[Musique]
à sin city si tu prends la bonne en réel
tu trouveras ce que tu cherches
voilà c'est qui celle ci
le trentenaire sortie le 1er juin avait
plus trop qui notre invité ce soir alors
franck muller a déclaré que sur le
tournage c'est vous qui l'avez le le
plus impressionné parmi tous les tous
les acteurs du film ça vous fait plaisir
ça on a dit tellement de mal de vous
[ __ ]
j'ai été beaucoup critiquée dans le
passé
mais avec le recul je pense que c'était
de ma faute alors les critiques saluent
votre prestation vous démarrez une
deuxième carrière avec ce fil est la
première était pourtant bien parti il y
a vingt ans après neuf semaines et demie
barfly en gerrard vous étiez une espèce
de superstar adulée par le monde entier
on parlait d'un nouveau james dean d'un
nouveau marlon brando mais parallèlement
à ces succès vous vous êtes créé une
réputation de bad guys sur les plateaux
et en dehors des plateaux est ce que
c'est vrai que vous traîniez avec tupac
le chef du gangsta rap
oui tout paquet mois et qui ont un très
amis nous avions beaucoup en commun
il est allé jusqu'à la limite ça lui a
coûté la vie
ça arrive vous étiez amis aussi avec
sony bagger le chef des hells angels
n'ont
jamais été très amis de leur club
pendant longtemps et j'en ai pas honte
et vous étiez ami avec john gotti qui
était un chef de la mafia c'est vrai
c'était un personnage fascinant alors
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque et vous l'avez
déclaré vous-même milk et vous dites
j'ai géré ma carrière d'une façon
désastreuse il ya une anecdote sur vous
qui est extraordinaire quand vous
appeliez sied où il y avait votre agent
vous connaissiez pas le nom de votre
agent et quand vous appeliez vous disiez
pas c'est moi le mec à la porsche rouge
c'est vrai ça
je voulais parler aux gars avec la
porsche blanche à bhl ans ouais c'est
vrai ça et c'est vrai qu'un jour dustin
hoffman nous ont envoyé le scénario de
rennes mais nous on vous proposons de
jouer le rôle que tom cruise a joué plus
tard et vous ce soir là vous aviez un
combat de boxe à dans le kansas et vous
avez même pas lu le scénario
ça s'est passé certes mais
il y avait un autre film
mais je veux pas rentrer dans les
détails ouais alors à l'époque milk
héros vous aviez tout un manoir une
rolls 10 motos une fille magnifique cave
l'iarc un parc incroyable côté de paris
non je confonds c'est pas le même mika
prendra
petit tombe la veste c'est pas bon signe
ouais ameline le tout schéma tout
regarde chez un bébé doc n ameline
alors l'époque mickey vous aviez tout un
manoir une rolls 10 motos une fille
magnifique karyotis vous dit j'avais
tout et j'ai tout foiré c'est un
désastre total au bac dan à l'époque je
ne me rendais pas compte que c'était de
ma faute je croyais que c'était la faute
de tous les autres je pensais que
c'était eux qui vous voulez alors
effectivement pourquoi pourrait-on se
dire pourquoi mickey rourke a tous
plantés c'est vrai que vous avez une
enfance difficile vous avez été
maltraités par le deuxième mari de votre
mère 1 explique keith l vous savez
vous savez quoi me caire je sais même
son nom ce gars s'appelait jean eddy
je vous en prie vous savez beaucoup de
choses il vous a traité comme un chien
ce type non
je ne répondrai pas
vous dites à l'époque j'avais la grosse
tête et je me prenais pour un génie
on gagnait beaucoup
tout le monde le lèche les bottes
on commence à se croire formidable
ça correspondait quelqu'un de
particulier
[Musique]
et on pense qu'on va jamais se retrouver
par terre et lorsqu'on tombe par terre
pense pas que ça va durer 12 13 ans
ouais
et puis vous aviez beaucoup la boxe
aussi vous avez commencé en boxant quand
vous étiez jeune et vous est remis à la
boxe vous avez pris plein de koudou les
opérations
5 opération du nez
je respire toujours pas par le démer je
me sens bien ouais
quand tarantino vous a proposé d'être le
boxeur dans pulp fiction à ce moment là
pourquoi vous avez refusé et mickey
je devais aller me battre
sassi qui
voile à l'époque vous perdez tout femme
un mini maison boulot et même vous dites
j'ai perdu mon âme vous vous retrouvez
tout seul vous dit un jour tu te
réveilles et tout s'est envolé à ce
moment là quand vous appelez le
restaurant il ya plus de place pour ce
qui s'est passé c'est que je me suis
regardé dans la glace un jour et je
ressemblais à marv personnages du film
là j'ai compris qu'il fallait changer
pour survivre vous en avez eu marre de
ce que vous étiez devenu à ce moment là
oui c'est moi qui ai changé personne
d'autre n'a changé pour moi alors il ya
eu des moments très difficiles il ya un
moment qui est extraordinaire c'est que
vous avez 200 $ par semaine pour vivre
et vous êtes obligés de faire vos
courses vous même dans un supermarché
vous poussez vous même le cas dit
non ce n'est vous tout cela vous allez
donc pour pas qu'on vous reconnaisse
vous allez dans le quartier gay vous
avez dans les supermarchés du quartier
gay à los angeles pour pas qu'on vous
reconnaît ses vrais
non c'est pas vrai
vous êtes catholique
il ya un moment où vous vous mettez à
genoux et vous demander à dieu de de
vous envoyer une petite lueur d'espoir
break tout à l'abri des messages eux le
fait de toute façon tous les jours alors
maintenant vous êtes devenu un good guys
mickey rourke est ce que vous fumer des
cigarettes non est ce que vous buvez de
l'alcool
est ce que vous vous droguer
ou
petite hésitation dirais quand même
est-ce que vous reboucher le tube de
dentifrice
est ce que vous laissez traîner vos
chaussettes par terre
est-ce que vous découpez la dinde le
jour de thanksgiving
non ça me ce négoce paul cohen
ok on va voir vous en êtes milk héros
qu'on va faire une hardy view
vous pensez à quoi en ce moment là
ce que je vais faire ce soir les cfd
nato gaza
le matin quand vous vous regardez dans
la glace vous pensez à quoi et c'est qui
celui-là
sommes
pas faire les mêmes erreurs fois que
dans le passé mais que souhaite mais
parce que en ce qui me concerne il faut
toujours que je travaille là dessus
retombé au chuté est ce qu'avec les
opérations quand vous vous regardez vous
vous reconnaissez ce que vous êtes
habitué à ce changement physique
je ne vois pas vraiment ce qu'ils ont
fait et parce qu'ils ont pris une petite
partie de mon oreille
pour hrw a sonné monde et cartonnage
votre plus belle histoire d'amour c'est
là qu'elle militait
à galles
j'ai compris la blague j'ai compris
tu as du temps d'annoncer laquelle
ça vous regarde pas
quand est-ce que vous avez pleuré pour
la dernière fois
david
dans ma chambre david a dû venir me
tenir par la main vous étiez triste
j'étais terrorisée pourquoi
je me suis bien amusé ici ça me plaît
ici
cette semaine sur mon mieux et ça fait
pas mal d'années
et son adresse
et ça m'a rappelé beaucoup de choses se
comprend vous seriez quoi en vous milk
et si vous aviez une baguette magique
dure question
en moi même
mais moi
j'aimerais apprendre à être seul sans
avoir besoin d'autrui ça ce serait bien
je pourrais rester dans ma chambre
j'avais sortir et être à l'aise
quel est le péché qui vous tente le plus
de chaînes et vous la luxure agneaux
fait la luxure que pourriez-vous dire de
plus négatif sur vous
j'ai des difficultés à communiquer avec
ma mère si votre vie était art fair milk
et qu'est-ce que vous changeriez
aux avenues et les 11 premières années
quelle est l'insulté qui vous a fait le
plus mal
probablement lorsque ma femme m'a quitté
j'en avais honte
aujourd'hui qui avez vous le plus envie
d'épater dans la vie
pour brigode dieu
que feriez vous s'il vous restait 24
heures à vivre chaque fois que bref
baiser ma femme un appareil
mais
quelle est la dernière personne que vous
ayez envie de tuer toi si tu insistes
parce que lorsque je discute de ça avec
un traître il m'a ordonné de prier à la
vierge marie et il m'a dit qu'il fallait
pas le faire d'accord
je n'ai pas le faire de toute façon
j'allais envoyer mes potes mais j'avais
déjà pensé au suicide
d'un cadre non je suis catholique je
n'ai pas le droit de me suicider et vous
vous avez ce que je prenais beaucoup de
drogue donc à un moment je voulais me
suicider et puis je vais pas fait aussi
parce que je pense que c'est pas bien
parce que je suis catholique aussi comme
vous
c'est tout ce qu'ils se droguent les
catholiques 1,5 c fouet
seller the sticks les transitions qu'est
ce que la vie vous a appris
à ne pas faire deux fois les mêmes
erreurs
comment aimeriez-vous mourir
sans souffrance vous voulez être
enterrés ou incinérés
makolo sais je ne réponds pas faut
commander maintenant par un procès des
rations il ya 20 minutes d'attentes
dr dornach
hockey pouvait mentir et maintenant on
l'a déjà enterré tellement de fois lui
et toute façon mickey est ce que vous
avez menti pendant cette interview
à l'exploit mais sauf que je fume vous
regretter d'être venu là pourquoi
je préfère être dans ma chambre certes
on va seul je suis très content de vous
revoir et je vous trouve beaucoup mieux
que la première fois que je vous ai vu
en 87 vous êtes beaucoup plus
sympathique à l'époque j'étais un peu
bad boy un peu casse couille quoi
j'aurais pas dit c'est à l'époque dans
le programme ps a fait un pas merci et
cinq
coups sûrs de ne rien rater le in
auditive abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou